[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur le
plateau de france 3 franche comté les 20
et 27 juin prochain nous allons voter à
la fois pour les élections régionales et
les élections départementales ce soir
place aux élections départementales et
pour le premier débat consacré à ces
départemental c'est la haute saône qui
ouvre le bal ce département de 238
l'habitant est découpé en dix-sept
cantons
chaque canton élira un binôme un homme
et une femme
ensuite c'est 34 conseillers
départementaux et les ronds à leur tour
un président ou une présidente
actuellement c'est yves krattinger le
président qui en est le président il est
divers gauche avec une majorité
confortable de 22 élus de gauche
auxquels il convient d'ajouter trois
élus de droite qui l'ont rejoint en
cours de mandat dans l'opposition neuf
élus de droite donc des adhérents chez
les républicains
et puis des divers droite alors je vous
présente les quatre invités qui vont
débattre durant près d'une heure de leur
programme de le projet pour ce
département de la haute saône tout
d'abord yves krattinger le président
divers gauche de ces départements depuis
20 ans il est candidat à sa propre
succession dans son canton est également
au poste de président face à lui alain
joyandet sénateurs des républicains il
est candidat dans un canton vésulien
s'ils l'emportent et si son camp
ravi suffisamment de canton à la gauche
il est également candidat pour être
président du département
de plus il est tête de liste et l'air
pour les élections régionales en haute
saône
quand afghans et membre du pcf le parti
communiste français
il est porte parole ici d'une union de
plusieurs partis le pc europe ecologie
les verts
la france a soumises grs c'est à dire la
gauche républicaine et socialistes ainsi
que génération et puis pour finir
antoine villedieu du rassemblement
national
le rn qui est présent dans tous les
cantons de la haute saône alors pour
commencer ce débat une première question
que je pose à léo quatre invités à
savoir pourquoi êtes vous candidat à ces
élections départementales
l'ordre a été tiré au sort tout à
l'heure et c'est à l'âge voyant des qui
a tiré le petit papier numéro un à la
genre ayant des pourquoi
vous candidat d'abord bonjour bonjour
aux auditeurs et bonjour à mes trois
collègues la haute saône est un
département bien malade
après vingt ans de socialisme les
fractures sont partout 20 ans dit
ratages et qui doit défendre son bilan
il ya ceux qui ont les routes qu'à ceux
qui n'en n'ont pas il ya ceux qui ont
des médecins ceux qui n'en n'ont pas et
le département ne sont n'occupe pas il
ya les endroits où on ferme brutalement
les collèges la liste est très très
longues et donc j'espère que nous allons
voir le temps de développer notre projet
le projet de toute une équipe qui a
rassemblé pour la haute saône pour tous
c'est ce que nous voulons faire la haute
saône pour tous et compte tenu de
l'expérience qui est la mienne compte
tenu de ce que j'ai pu faire pour vesoul
qui est constaté personne ne le conteste
mes amis m'ont demandé de piloter cette
élection départementale et c'est un
grand plaisir que j'accepte ce nouveau
défi pour mon département parce que
gelée au coeur en toi de villedieu pour
le rassemblement national vous
intervenez en deuxième position bonjour
à tous donc moi je suis candidat parce
que je crois en l'avenir de la haute
saône je crois en l'avenir de la haute
saône et je veux lui offrir cette vision
pour le futur rebattent les cartes et
porter une nouvelle dynamique
départementale des projets structurants
pour notre département dans l' écoute la
proximité et la concertation n'ont pas
en décrue en déconstruisant pardon ce
qui a été construit pendant des années
mais en bâtissant de nouvelles bases
ces bases aujourd'hui ce sont les hôtes
saônois ce sont nos territoires
ce sont nos communes notre patrimoine et
notre identité
on aura l'occasion donc débattre de vos
propositions durant les cinquante
minutes qui viennent
quant à ce poste pour le parti
communiste la suite suite à la crise
sanitaire il va falloir faire face à la
crise sociale qui arrive le département
c'est une des compétences principales la
question sociale
notre collectif donc comme vous avez dit
inquiet représente toutes les formations
vous avez déjà énoncé et c'est une
première en haute saône
ce rassemblement des forces de gauche a
pour ambition de de rompre avec 20 ans
de de gestion
ratage east est aujourd'hui macro nist
nous voulons ramener effectivement le
département à sa gauche et parce que
monsieur krattinger accompagner le
désengagement de l'état dans la casse du
service public et dans la casse sociale
finalement il krattinger attirer le
petit numéro 4 donc c'est à vous de
gérer conclure cette introduction
tout au long du mondial les gens m'ont
soutenu et encouragé ça mobilise mon
énergie
ça renforce mon mon amour pour la haute
saône et pour ses habitants
j'ai une majorité très unie qui on va
attendre n'a jamais fait apparaître une
division dans la presse ou dans
l'hémicycle quand on compare avec
certaine cacophonie
on peut se réjouir l'attitude des élus
haut saônois majorité qui est courageuse
qui écarte toute démagogie et puis j'ai
toujours l'envié l'envi et des projets à
concrétiser deux nous allons parler pour
la haute saône la haute saône
nous l'aimons nous essayons de la
bonifier de la rendre plus fier très
bien donc je vous propose d'aborder le
premier thème donc dans ce débat à
savoir les routes les infrastructures
c'est l'un des postes des dépenses très
important dans un département en haute
saône et je parle sous votre contrôle
ils ratent âgées 282 millions de
dépenses 53 millions pour les routes
c'est beaucoup beaucoup d'argent qu'avez
vous fait pour désenclaver la haute
saône juste quelques secondes pour
résumer ce que vous avez fait et on je
vous propose un tour de table pour
savoir ce que vous adversaires
politiques
on pense pour les routes nous avons un
grand bilan 69 km qui ont été mis à deux
fois deux voies
5 millions d'euros par an du département
sur les routes de l'état en comparaison
dans une période antérieure jeunes
départ gouvernants un million d'euros
par an alors que nous sommes à 5
et 10 km de droit de deux fois deux fois
en dix ans le retour à 90 capteurs
méthode parce qu'il faut l'évoquer tout
le monde sait que je suis pour
je proposerai si je suis dit long le
retour sur 505 km qui ont déjà été
déterminé par ailleurs ailleurs nous
avons des priorités est la priorité des
priorités c'est de lure vers vesoul en
commençant par en blanc je devrais y est
pour moi tout ça c'est la déviation la
fameuse déviation choses sont claires
nous continuerons à travailler avec
l'état et avec un région pour construire
des infrastructures de qualité qui
permettent de connecter la automne au
territoire qui l'entourent on va faire
un petit tour de table tentative cost
donc du parti communiste que pensez vous
de la politique route dans la 2 yves
krattinger ce que pour moi c'était et
cdt plus vous c'était plus la majorité
qu'est ce que vous en pensez je pense
qu'il est peut-être temps de ralentir
les choses là où je suis d'accord c'est
qu'effectivement il ya une priorité
notamment sur le sur le contournement
damblanc jeunes devraient y est pour moi
après est ce nécessaire de passer en 2 x
2 je pense que une deux voies est bien
suffisante pour contourner cette route
qui est accidentogène et lé les
habitants de ces trois villages
subissent régulièrement la circulation
mais vous êtes priorité donc à ces
déviations
cette déviation wii et sur le reste
évitons de mon livre on aime agricole
voilà on le vole eux vont un peu le pied
antoine villedieu pour le rassemblement
national
alors moi je vais commencer par
reconnaître qu'effectivement le
désenclavement vers la ville de besançon
a été fait c'est des portions de routes
qui ont été faits petit à petit et qui
ont amené une deux fois deux
pratiquement jeu
ce que besançon néanmoins si ces textes
a été travaillée on voit bien que en
direction lure ya rien moi que j'ai
rencontré les habitants de pau mois de
jeûne breuil dans blanc c'est des
promesses qu'ils entendent depuis des
dizaines d'années j'ai même une personne
qui m'a confié que quand il a acheté sa
maison en 1961 le notaire lui a dit vous
avez de la chance il va y avoir une
déviation
ah oui je connais la réponse c'est
d'être des projets qui prennent du temps
il faut que l'état soit d'accord et
c'est donc nous on est vraiment pour
irriguer nos communes rurales pour
développer des axes routiers qui
favoriseront l'implantation
d'entreprises
bonjour vous êtes déviait si on est bien
allé partout on sait on s'est clairement
positionné comme étant notre projet
enfin un des projets qu'on votera dans
les premiers mois de notre mandat est
l'âge orientée qu est ce que vous pensez
quand même pas faire le débat autour de
pau moi alors que ça fait 20 ans que
monsieur krattinger elle est là ça fait
20 ans qu'il a mis le dossier sous la
table et qui n'annonce aujourd'hui que
c'est prioritaire dans le dernier
rapport au conseil départemental
il ya trois lignes sur sept ans sur cet
endroit et y en a beaucoup beaucoup
d'autres sur l'a57 bref pour faire vite
je crois que oui un lourd bilan sur les
routes mais c'est un véritable scandale
politique pour moi les routes c'est un
scandale politique il suffit de se
promener en haute saône
tout a été concentrée who are you et
héricourt 80% du territoire de la haute
saône qui a été écarté l'agglomération
de vesoul écarté j'ai été maire pendant
17 ans où il suffit de se promener 27
mille véhicules à la vaugine à vesoul
alors j'explique carrefour de la vaugine
légèrement bien c'est sur la zone
commerciale je viendrai juste à côté
d'eux ne vous inquiétez pas les haut
saônois qui savent où est pour moi ils
savent aussi appliqué aussi oui
ouais pour moi peut-être voyez vous donc
je dis simplement que c'est un scandale
que 80% du département a été ignoré le
centre le nord l'ouest
rien depuis 20 ans 80% de la production
80% de la production industrielle le
contournement de port-sur-saône c'est
moi qui l'ait décidé quand j'étais au
gouvernement une c'est ça la vérité n 10
mille véhicules par an are you on passe
sur une deux fois deux voies je me
demandais d'ailleurs qu'elle bloquait
loriot il s'agit c'est parce que je
passe sur une magnifique deux fois deux
voies
je vois rio nord rio sud c'est la très
très grande agglomération d'oriola lâché
aussi une parenthèse mais si vous n'avez
pas j'ai ordinaire de rio il a été
procédé pour leur mental là bas ils me
regardaient pas interrompu les autres
candidats annoncés en même temps ils
auront tout le temps de me répondre je
dis juste que sur les routes
je vais expliquer pourquoi vous attaquez
sur rio pour que votre propos soient
plus claires pour ceux qui ne savent pas
mais tout le monde connaît le président
du conseil départemental de la notion d
d'où il est originaire donc si je peux
terminer mon propos sur les routes parce
que je confirme et je pèse mes mots et
je le redis je trouve que c'est un
scandale politique parce qu'on a toutes
ignorées
et en août on a tout abandonné
l'autoroute le contournement nord de
vesoul le contournement degrés annoncés
avant les dernières cantonales supprimés
après comme par hasard est maintenant
l'actualité l'actualité c'est le
contournement est de vesoul qui depuis
trois jours est à nouveau aux calendes
grecques
c'est un dossier qui date d'il ya vingt
ans comme par hasard on a lancé une
enquête publique avant les élections
quant à notre arc krattinger le monde
bien sûr mais bien sûr mais moi je sur
ce sujet là je peux pas laisser dire si
vous voulez que le bilan et est
important il est lourd mais il est lourd
sens négatif et je pense que c'est
d'ailleurs une des raisons
une des raisons qui ont fondé ma
candidature parce que je pense qu'on
peut plus continuer comme ça pour
l'avenir du département et pour l'avenir
des jeunes de notre département et de
ses emplois la parole est à yves
krattinger lure luxeuil à deux fois deux
voies celle département et vos amis ne
l'ont pas voté
lure et héricourt à deux fois dehors ils
ont bien c'est celle département et ils
ont bien fait là par contre vos amis
l'ont voté
dire que rien n'a été fait à l'est c'est
un mensonge une participation financière
vient dire le contrat l'aménagement de
la déviation de vieillir le compte nos
participations foot au contournement de
luxeuil tout cela nous l'avons financé
avec l'état et parfois tout seul est ce
que c'est le rôle d'un département de
pallier les défaillances de l'état
la question se pose quand même hein
c'est une très bonne question
merci dans le dernier contrat de plan
qui était au niveau de la franche-comté
seulement la haute saône a obtenu 66 %
des crédits plus plus sans rien payer
duff c'est à 36 les autres ne participe
pas ça veut dire que vous avez bien
défendu et les intéressés par la mode et
on dira c'est aux gens les autres
départements ne veulent pas participer
de son libre ne nous regarde pas ils ont
préféré participer et avancer et avancer
beaucoup à mon ouïe animaux je dis que
c'est une grosse erreur je pense qu'il
ya pas de quoi être fier de faire payer
dans les contribuables haut saônois les
routes nationales bien sûr que les
autres départements aux raisons d'aller
chercher des routes nationales n ont
financé financés par les crédits
nationaux
vous avez même fait longtemps qu'ils
avaient même créé sur l'a57 une sur la
sur la nationale 57 récemment une
portion qui était pas du tout urgente en
direction de rio financé à 100% par les
impôts des contribuables départementaux
et régionaux sans un sou de l'état
quant aux encore du sens au barreau lure
luxeuil
mais c'est une erreur stratégique
majeure messieurs krattinger majeur
parce que l'urgence elle est où
l'urgence et les autres luxeuil et
vesoul et surtout entre lure et vesoul
et pas entre luxeuil et l'eures
ça n'est pas du tout un influent de
développement économique naturel est
intéressante l'idée c'est quoi c'est de
continuer à écarter l'agglomération de
vesoul est celle de luxeuil
on veut donc on est en désaccord total
sur votre stratégie
c'est vrai qu'on a un désaccord ah ça
c'est clair je vais vous demander
monsieur juste encore un petit mot pour
conclure sur ce chapitre des routes
qu'avez-vous
a ajouté quentin frost j'aurai deux
choses je ne peux que me réjouir de
l'avis défavorable du commissaire
enquêteur concernant la déviation est de
vesoul à ce qu'elle soit un bon signe
c'est un dossier délicat mais il ya eu
un calcul coût avantage et le coût
environnemental était bien trop élevé et
c'est pour ça que je ne peux que saluer
cette décision
et la deuxième chose le budget route
2021 si je me trompe pas ces 38 millions
d'euros
un tas peut près de 12% du budget c'est
plus que la part allouée au rsa antoine
villedieu le rsa on y reviendra tout à
l'heure en tout une ville du un petit
mot pour conclure sur ce chapitre des
routines alors pour ma part je pense
qu'il faut revoir toute la stratégie
départementale concernant la
construction des routes
effectivement je vais je vais rejoindre
alain joyandet
on a quand même quelques accords sur le
fait que la priorité n'était pas lure
luxeuil
mais bien dirigés luxeuil et vesoul qui
est une route très accidentogène lure à
vesoul et de permettre ainsi de nourrir
aussi nos territoires les plus reculés
aujourd'hui on a un enclavement de la
ruralité faux dépend des métropoles à
des métropoles de la ville en tout cas
c'est à dire condéon métropolis en
quelque sorte le même en haute saône à
département des rails s'il en est pas
rigoler je pense non mais que je vous
comprenez bien le terme un jeu vous l'a
promis qu'il a une grosse grosse ville
comme vesunna partout sur les
agglomérations et on laisse en fait un
outil au petit village dépérir au plus
loin
très bien je voudrais que l'on passe
maintenant aux thèmes suivants à savoir
les collèges c'est la dernière polémique
en date on a pu donc en entendre parler
pas mal
rappel des épisodes précédents pour ceux
qui n'habitent ni vesoul ni la haute
saône et qui sont un petit peu plus loin
même si à la joyeuse n est pas d'accord
quand je quand je recontextualise un peu
les choses
alors le collège jérôme donc jérôme
c'est un pâtre vésulien du 19e siècle
le collège va devenir notamment un
centre d'apprentissage et les élèves
seront répartis sur plusieurs collèges
donc dans sur la commune de vesoul
et ça crée pas mal de polémiques yves
krattinger très rapidement cette fois ci
qu'est ce que vous avez prévu donc à la
cité géraud et ont fait un tour de table
pour savoir ce que pensent les uns et
des autres là c'était jérôme
n'appartient pas au département donc
c'est quand même le propriétaire c'est à
dire ces boules qui décident de l'avenir
la cité jérôme le projet qui était
élaboré par vesoul me semble excellent
elle nous aideront à sa réalisation si
je suis en situation
c'est à dire il dit à des bâtiments qui
font dix mille mètres carrés sur trois
hectares de terrain des bâtiments qui
datent du xviie siècle
vous voulez notamment et installer un
cfa vesoul résoudre est avec vous un
camion cross départemental c'est quand
même un peu d'argent quand même j'ai dit
que nous soutiendrions financièrement
l'opération
oui parce que il faut quand même
accueillir les élèves dans d'autres
collèges et là c'est votre compétence
d'autres compétences non mais voilà
qu'au que l'on comprenne à peu près les
choses qu'un jour là perdu un peu plus
de 600 élèves sur un période
donc c'est la faute de la démographie
voilà j'écoutais que tu es 600 élèves de
moi qu'il ya 2400 élèves dans les
collèges sont les quatre collèges de
l'agglo au départ et qu'on descend à 6
ans moi il ya un moment donné il faut
c'est être capable de tirer des
enseignements d'une situation cependant
que les provoquer antoine ville que pour
le rassemblement national la cité jérôme
oui ou non si vous êtes demain président
du département parce que c'est aussi
votre ambition
qu'est ce que vous faites avec ce projet
aujourd'hui la cité jérôme la ville
krattinger l'a bien rappelé
effectivement c'est un projet qui est
qui a été initiée par la ville de vesoul
un projet d'y installer un centre de
formation des apprentis qui jusqu'àlors
est situé espace de la motte sur le
projet de fond on est plutôt d'accord
parce que la cité jérôme aujourd'hui
depuis qu'elle a été fermé nécessitant
un coup réhabilitation assez important
il ya des travaux qui sont entrepris qui
sont assez faramineux
les budgets ont été votés la région
précédemment c'est un budget de 15
millions d'euros
si je dis pas de bêtises donc
aujourd'hui stoppée et vouloir réouvrir
pour moi c'est de la pure démagogie et
ouvrir un collège dans un établissement
qui a été fermé refaire venir les
enseignants remettre en place tout le
système éducatif tout les tous les
accords qui ont été passés que
l'éducation nationale c'est simplement
impossible
quant à khost il ya plusieurs problèmes
par rapport à ses collèges je rejoins
monsieur monsieur krattinger il ya un
problème de démographie
si on a fermé ses trois collèges il ya
donc la démographie ya le problème aussi
que c'était des bâtiments extrêmement
énergivore après j'entends la
proposition de monsieur joyandet dans ce
cas là je dis chiche puisque son
argument c'est de faire des collèges à
taille humaine donc dans ce cas là
monsieur je pense qu'il faut aussi
s'interroger du coup sûr le collège
pierre et marie curie 1 qui en terme de
nombre d'élèves est quand même plutôt
grand et le collège allure albert
jacquard aussi donc soit on fait le
choix effectivement de collège à taille
humaine soit on fait aussi un choix de
raison liée à la démographie et auquel
cas nos 26 collèges existants avec tout
l'investissement nécessaire pour les
rendre performant et j'ai
énergétiquement sera déjà un bon projet
à l'âge orienté alors donc en toi 2010
démagogie si on veut rouvrir le collège
héros vous c'est ce que vous envisagez
si vous êtes président ce que je veut
déjà dire c'est que si lui un changement
de majorité nous prenons un engagement
très ferme
il n'y aura aucune fermeture de collège
dans tout le département pendant les
sept ans parce que c'est un mandat très
longue c'est un mandat de sept ans
pendant les sept ans de notre mandat en
haute saône
je rejoins ce qui vient d'être dit nous
sommes pour des collèges à taille
humaine des collèges de proximité qu'est
ce que ça veut dire dans un département
comme la haute saône et c c'est le
raisonnement habituel de monsieur
krattinger ya pas assez de voiture donc
je fais pas de route
y'a pas assez d'élèves je fermais
collège dans un endroit de la ruralité
où il n'y a pas assez de vie eh ben on
enferme encore plus le département de la
haute saône comme tous les départements
ruraux
le conseil départemental son rôle majeur
pour moi c'est un rôle de régulateur
régulation du département d'apporter
plus à ceux qui ont moins
parce que si on continue comme ça on
peut fermer la moitié du département
je pense à tout le nord de la haute
saône qui est en zone de fragilité
alors ils n'ont plus droit des collèges
de proximité ils n'ont plus droit à des
routes lors du précédent débat monsieur
krattinger 10l hors de question de faire
une autoroute à l'ouest de port sur
saône ya que 3600 au 3900 véhicule c'est
exactement ce qui nous a dit alors à ce
moment-là on ferme la route
on voulait ouvrir jérôme non pas juste
j'ai dit depuis le début que si la
collectivité locale la communauté
éducative le souhaitaient donnerions les
moyens d'une réouverture de la les voilà
ce que je dis depuis le début donc dans
la cohérence de mes propos nous nous
enfermerons aucun jeudi aux habitants de
vauvillers à ceux de fauconnier qui ont
été sur la sellette à cause des
déclarations monsieur ratages et je le
redis dormez tranquilles nora von d y
aura pas autant de jeux krattinger moi
j'ai en tête
moi je savais j'ai un engagement en
politique j'ai toujours fait ça j'ai
toujours fait ça et je dis ce que je
vais faire et je fais ce que j'ai dit ne
vous pouvez pas nous dire que la
priorité c'est en blanc après 20 ans de
la ville vous pouvez pas nous dire que
vous n'avez pas fermer le collège c'est
votre système de raisonnement on a c'est
vrai haxhi accepter votre système de
raisonnement vous avez un système de
raisonnement qui consiste à dire là où
il n'y a pas beaucoup et pas y aura plus
rien mais non on va tout à l'heure on a
dit tout à l'heure vous avez dit mon
voisin a dit quelque chose d'intéressant
en parlant des routes il a dit c'est
effectivement on a désenclavé besançon
bah oui c'est vrai on a offert les ans
on oui on a au fait mais c'est la vérité
parce qu'on a offert des routes on à
faire des routes on a offert des routes
au nord de besançon comme ça les
bisontins peuvent aller un petit peu à
l'intérieur de la haute saône mais
qu'est ce qu'on a fait pour tous ces
gens là ont pour les collèges c'est
exactement la même chose il faut
absolument des collèges de proximité il
faut partout on laisse répondu yves
krattinger et on passe aux thèmes
suivants lure luxeuil à défaut de voir
le luxe elle avant lui ré recours à de
faux devant l aire urbaine c'est pas
dans le sud bon je passe au collège au
collège l'assemblée a voté à voter en
disant fauconnier est maintenu et
vauvillers est maintenu alors pourquoi
vous ressortez ce alors que vous le
savez
j'espérais venir et sion viennent je
vous laisse je vous demande de me
laisser quand même faire apprendre on
abandonne les collèges on a battu
notre record d'investissements dans ce
mandat sur les collèges 75 millions
d'euros
marc modernisation isolation des
bâtiments fibre optique sur tous les
sites avec un groupement fermé
l'utilisateur 8000 tablette pour les
collégiens circuits courts dans les
assiettes deuxième dans le classement
national à vie locale la lutte contre le
gaspillage alimentaire cinq couverts du
collège ce qu'on appelle des collèges
ouvert et ça mérite quand même vrai mais
on n'aura pas le temps aujourd'hui d'en
parler ils sont il faut il sauver qui
sont fauconnière sur salon noidans les
vesoul et jus c'est toujours toujours
l'intérêt général en comparaison même si
je lui en ai pas ce que vous avez occupé
des fonctions au département des vingt
ans les autres on ne peut pas leur
reprocher ils ne les ont pas occupé il
ya 20 ans mais quand même j'ai regardé
les chiffres nous avons regardé les
chiffres nous dépensons chaque année
dans les collèges vie fois plus que ce
que vous dépensez autant aux était parmi
les responsables
le 20 ans que pour nous la jeunesse on
investit et on fait ce qu'il faut
ce qui est nécessaire bon on va passer
au thème suivant il s'agit du social
l'action sociale dans un département
c'est en général le plus gros poste de
dépense donc 109 millions d'euros en
haute saône sur un budget de 282
millions d'euros de dépenses et on va
commencer parce que vous êtes un petit
peu en retard avec antoine villedieu et
quant à lacoste doux pour le
rassemblement national et pour le pc on
va commencer avec vous il reste un peu
plus de 27 minutes
dans ce débat si vous êtes président du
département de haute soule en matière
sociale que faites vous alors je pense
qu'en matière sociale on va on va
pouvoir discuter d'une chose 7,3
millions d'euros 3 millions d'euros
c'est le budget qui est alloué par le
département de haute saône pour les
mineurs non accompagnés
3 millions d'euros qui si demain nous
sommes alors que je précise des mineurs
non accompagnés ce sont les donc des
gens de moins de 18 ans qui arrive de
l'étranger
on est bien dans son plan de ce temps
situation irrégulière dont près la
respectent pas nos lois mais sa finance
d'après-vous 3 millions se donneront
celle d'après les chiffres du
département
voilà trois ans madame et moi donc
plutôt que de financer des mineurs
l'étranger ou de d'aidé au logement des
clandestins et lui nous investirons dans
l'éducation de nos enfants dont
l'insertion au handicap dans le
bien-être de nos aînés et tout c'est
toutes ces mesures on l'est on les
développe donc pour les aînés avec le
maintien à domicile en proposant une
certaine alternance à l'ehpad le
maintien à domicile avec le financement
de maison l'âge d'or des appartements
individuels où les habitants peuvent se
retrouver puis là vous devenez
promoteurs immobiliers promoteurs
immobiliers je je je fais la promotion
d'une alternative à l'ehpad mais il faut
que ce soit des privés qui investissent
sur le départ métaux notamment la dame
en pour le social on a aussi prévu de
renforcer la lutte contre la fraude
sociale
aujourd'hui la fraude sociale c'était
plus d'un milliard par an en france en
france où il a évidemment j ai peur que
ces soirs où tu sais il y aurait de
l'argent aller chercher au moins donc un
milliard par an on peut dire que
peut-être on peut récupérer quelques
millions d'ailleurs monsieur ciotti le
président des alpes maritimes ont
renforcé et république des républicains
ont renforcé la lutte contre la fraude
sociale ce qui a permis de récolter de
2009 à 2020 17 millions d'euros
je vous arrête là parce que vous avez
donc déjà énuméré plusieurs mesures
je vais demander à compter un frost ce
qu'ils en pensent l'action sociale pour
vous est ce que c'est
les mineurs donc non accompagné les
mineurs isolés
est ce que c'est la fraude ou est ce que
ce sont d'autres réalisations que vous
souhaiteriez une fois encore là dessus
je m'inscris en faux par rapport à un
rassemblement national moi je ne suis
pas là pour diviser les les êtres
humains entre eux et les catégoriser g7
à un constat factuel
non non à quel moment j'ai divisé et
concernant la fraude sociale pour moi il
serait plutôt intéressant d'aller
chercher la fraude fiscale mais c'est
une compétence de l'état
là encore une fois quand on voit le
budget social du département et qu'on
compare
par rapport aux autres strates on se
rend compte qu'on est en dessous de la
moyenne nationale vous dit autre stat
strates c'est à dire les départements de
même population
voilà c'est ça on est à peu près enfin
la moyenne nationale c'est à peu près 60
4% on est autour de 58 % de notre
fonctionnement
donc c'est quand même énorme deux points
supplémentaires sur notre budget de
fonctionnement
ça permettrait de financer par exemple
le rsa jeunes en haute-saône 1 contre ce
que vous c'est donc une de vos
propositions c'est le rsa jeunes
d'ailleurs qu'il ya un certain nombre de
jeunes les 18 25 ans sont sont
aujourd'hui écartée des aides il faut
avoir au minimum 25 ans pour pouvoir
bénéficier du rsa et cette semaine anne
hidalgo et des présidents socialistes de
conseils départementaux ont demandé que
le rsa jeune soit inscrit donc au
programme de l'état donc vous c'est en
fait vous qu'on comprenne bien le rsa
c'est une allocation spécifique pour les
jeunes qu'ils soient étudiants ou
chômeurs exactement l'objectif c'est de
laisser de les accompagner dans l'emploi
elle lui garantir une certaine autonomie
pour accéder souvent c'est c'est un
premier accès à l'emploi donc c'est
nécessaire de les accompagner
sachant que le rsa il ya toujours un
volet insertion on ne donne pas laide
comme ça il ya un volet insertion qui
doit être fait et un montant de combien
du rsa les jeunes on n'a encore pas
estimer mais on est autour de l'existant
aujourd'hui quoi sur le même montant
après on est typiquement fait sur des
propositions de l'extrême gauche
c'est-à-dire saidal et et les gens et
puis d'éviter de les remettre au travail
nous on est pour le rsa le proposer
contre 1 comment dire l'insertion par
l'emploi c'est-à-dire de sensibiliser
les gens avec des travaux d'être
bénévole dans de l'associatif et c'est
donc c'est un échange saint tropez vous
toucher une allocation mais vous donner
des heures de travail
on ne peut pas toujours tout donné sans
contrepartie
si l'insertion effectivement est quelque
chose d'important
il faut aussi permettre aux gens aux
jeunes aux moins jeunes de vouloir
sincères et c'est pas en finançant
le débit canapé qu'on va réussir à
relancer l'économie et à inciter les
gens à travailler quand on est jeune je
veux dire le rsa il sert il sert paloise
if they est loin de la sphère faire
faire conditionner à du bénévolat c'est
finalement une double peine parce que
pendant que le jeune homme est en train
de faire du bénévolat il ne s'inspire
pas professionnellement il ne cherche
pas un emploi deuxièmement c'est laisser
parler s'il vous plaît ce rsa
il sert aussi à avoir une sorte de
revenu minimum parce que quand on a 18
25 ans on a un permis à payer on a des
assurances on a on a un certain nombre
aussi de freins pour aller chercher un
emploi et le rsa permet justement de
faciliter cette insertion alain joyandet
votre action sociale si vous êtes
président du département de la haute
saône
quelle serait-elle est ce que ce serait
comme dit antoine villedieu qui cite
eric ciotti des républicains déjà lutter
contre la fraude pour moi dans les
compétences du département
l'action sociale première des actions
sociales c'est d'assurer la sécurité
sanitaire et la sécurité de la santé la
compétence essentielle du département
sont les personnes âgées et quand même
faut pas l'oublier sur le budget vous
aviez presque 40% du budget de la haute
saône qui est consacrée au global à ses
différentes missions dans le cadre de
l'action sociale il ya un sujet qui nous
nous fait particulièrement peur pour
l'avenir c'est le problème du désert
médical
comment parler de maintenir les
personnes âgées à domicile
comment parler d' améliorer la qualité
sanitaire dans les ehpad
si nous n'avons plus de médecins
médecins généralistes médecins
spécialistes
j'annonce et je confirme que si je suis
président du département de la haute
saône
la première chose que je ferai comme
cela a été fait en saône et loire c'est
de créer les conditions pour recruter 50
médecins dans les trois ans qui viennent
des médecins salariés du département
comme ça se passe en saône et loire en
totale complémentarité de la médecine
libérale est en accord avec la médecine
libérale en accord avec l'hôpital public
dont j'ai été le président pendant 23
ans qui rapporteur du budget de la santé
au parlement c'est vraiment un sujet que
je connais beaucoup et auquel j'attache
énormément énormément d'importance et
pour moi évidemment qu'on peut avoir des
débats sur un certain nombre de sujets
mais pour moi l'objectif premier
premiers ont reçu les premières actions
vous la première action la première
action pour moi c'est ça tout de suite
mettre en place les conditions du
recrutement savez on a un très grand
nombre de médecins qui ont plus de 55
ans on a une chute en disant de 12 5% du
nombre de médecins généralistes en
dessous de la moyenne nationale est à
neuf il faut faire quelque chose
urgemment comment comment continuer
comme ça dans le nord du département une
partie de l'ouest aussi partie du
nord-est a déjà beaucoup d' alerte
qu'ils se sont donnés une fois de plus
su pas sur la même ligne que monsieur
krattinger parce que quand je lui en
parle quand il ya plus de médecins à
sollenau il répond c'est pas grave on
peut aller chez le médecin héricourt
serre 20 km ou à quelques kilomètres
c'est j'espère que c'est pas possible
c'est pas que je vais là à la wii va me
répondre je vais répondre d'abord sur le
meddat mineurs non accompagnés de normes
d'accompagner 3 millions d'euros c'est
ce que ça coûte
c'est le chiffre qui l'a avancé je
tribune besoin je veux répondre parce
qu'on peut pas causer comme ça on répond
tu sais quoi c'est une obligation
tout jeune de moins de 18 ans situé sur
territoire départemental qui n'est pas
lié à une famille à des parents est mis
sous la protection du président du
conseil du département ou de la
présidente
c'est comme ça c'est la loi la loi elle
est comme ça personne ne peut dire on ne
fait pas s'il faut plus appliquer les
lois là je comprends pas très bien ce
qu'on fait là bas la minorité elle a
évalué très sérieusement avec des tests
osseux moi je veux finir non non non non
non vous le laissez poser une question
répond très activement la haute saône
nous n'avons pas de radicalisation des
maynats à ce jour et nous avons toujours
vu avec l'état en disant si un moindre
alerte
on vous fera passer la situation roy
hodgson il synthèse c'est pas moi qui le
dit dans des filières économiques et ya
un certain nombre de chefs d'entreprise
sur la restauration sur l'économie sur
l'industrie sur les services à la
personne sur les services des espaces
verts etc qui nous sollicitent pour
qu'on en prépa et qu'on les forme voilà
le coup en haute saône pour être précis
pour nous le prix de revient aujourd'hui
il est de 20 et amis les quelques europa
et menin le budget a été fait plus gros
parce qu'on ne sait pas s'il y aura à
nouveau une vague ou pas on est plutôt
en haut à ses bases sur les ménages
actuellement
moi j'ai remplir et toujours la mission
qui m'est confiée par l'état
je ne déborderaient jamais je ne garde
nous ne sommes pas une république
indépendante
nous sommes responsables de ce qu'on
nous confie le rsa oui le rsa le rsa
jeunes l'airé sa jeune mais pas
seulement parce que le rsa on fait comme
si on ne faisait rien on a monté deux
missions essentielles
la première c'est ce qu'on a appelé le
juste droit juste droit il a contribué à
voir s'il ya des situations qui était
pas correct des fraudes non à corps et à
correct et aujourd'hui alors que nous
avons pu en trois ans de travail baisser
le nombre de ressortissants du rsa de
20% premier prix national
un prix remis au sénat d'ailleurs
monsieur le sénateur 1 je tiens à le
dire par une sénatrice et donc alors que
nous avons fait ça nous savons que la
relocation elle n'a pas baissé d'autant
parce qu'en fait on a découvert des gens
qui ne sachant pas très bien remplies et
qu'il n'y avait pas eu droit et qui
touchait et tony avaient alors six ans
le danois touché moi parce qu'ils
avaient droit parce que leur situation
change souvent malheureusement pour eux
c'est très compliqué et nous nous devons
d'adapter évidemment d'autres versements
et quand ils augmentent ils rencontrent
donc pour nous c'est quelque chose de
très sérieux mais les 20% de baisse ils
ont été plébiscités dans la crise c'est
remonter pour une part pas au même
niveau qu'avant mais les deux derniers
trimestres le dernier de 2020 et le
premier bilan des pertes entre serrar
des sens où ils m'écoutent et c'est des
questions essentielles moi je viens est
attaquée mais je vais pouvoir répondre
sinon qu'est-ce que je fais là 1 alors
la troisième question sur la santé
un excusé de la situation si la santé a
été passée au département chez pas vu le
texte parlementaire qu'ils disent
un pour le moment la santé c'est l'état
est franchement dans la crise
on a pu mesurer que la grèce voulait
maintenir toutes les manettes de la
santé entre ses mains ça veut pas dire
qu'on ne fait rien on aide les maisons
de santé
c'est une très bonne chose bien sûr mais
ça ne suffit pas d'aider les maisons de
santé
bien sûr que c'est encore insuffisant
ceci dit on fera ce que monsieur le
maire actuel de vesoul a fait on
apportera des bourses supplémentaires
pour des jeunes qui viendrait faire leur
formation au talkie 6 10 pour le moment
on s'aperçoit très vite que au moment où
la période de formation est finie ils
vont voir le banquier qui leur prête de
l'argent
mais ils repartent mais c'est une chose
mais il ya quand même une réponse qui
est une réponse législative pour être
clair législatives qui est très
important bon le numerus clausus aurait
sauté c'est ce qu'on nous dit y en a
vraiment besoin l'italie l'a supprimée y
adhérent l'univers geek clausus c'est le
nombre d'étudiants en médecine en
formation est ce que l'état n'a pas le
droit de me salir et que tous les dix
ans avant nous les médecins ont plus de
63 ans viennent en france en italie on
peut plus exercer à 4 63 ans
c'est impératif de deuxième élément il
n'y a pas que ça il ya des zones en
déprises le plan médical il en est en
route souvenir non ce sont des lois il
n'a encore en saône-et-loire d'ailleurs
il ya eu au département et d'ailleurs
n'ont pas recruté comme la sono crache
sur le remarquerait départements de
notre région qu'il a fait est peut-être
pas beaucoup en france
simplement si la nation décider enfin
que les nouveaux médecins pour avoir
l'agrément sécurité sociale dont
s'inscrit s'installer dans des zones qui
ne sont pas qu'ils sont déficitaires en
praticien bas services de cloud vous
êtes en train de beauté au parlement je
bois je dis que ce que 85% des français
répondent dans les sondages ton nom ton
contient h cost est en retard alors vous
par rapport au social qu'est ce que vous
proposez de plus que ce que nous avait
dit tout à l'heure à savoir donc le rsa
jeunes est ce que vous proposez des
choses on va peut-être plus répondre je
leur réponds en une phrase je crois
d'ailleurs à avoir signé la pétition
nationale en faveur j'aimerais bien
qu'on l'appelle pas rsa jeunes voilà
mais vous êtes d'accord pour finances
sur le principe c'est de la location il
faut aider les jeunes que pour le moulin
les personnes âgées voudrais pas qu'on
appellerait 100 personnes âgées
peut-être on sait du cosmétique 1
j'ai juste quand même rebondir c'est à
dire qu'au final sur le rsa jeunes dont
il a fait une réponse courte mais
aujourd'hui à la part budgétaire pour
les jeunes éligibles les jeunes non
éligible aujourd'hui c'est trois cent
mille euros
à savoir que dans le budget 1 770 milles
euros c'est le budget de la planche des
belles filles
donc voilà la politique en faveur de la
jeunesse de monsieur krattinger et les
personnes âgées un mot peut-être quand
même il ya aussi par exemple sur sur la
hache déjà un l'aide à l'autonomie
handicapés il faut savoir aujourd'hui
que la moyenne nationale
en moyenne ces populations handicapées
sont trois fois plus pauvres et ils ont
un reste à vivre extrêmement faibles
faible et je pense qu'il faut qu'on
augmente la prestation de compensation
du handicap
ça fait partie de nos propositions c'est
l'état l'état qui le fait mais il faut
qu'on puisse accompagner différemment on
a il ya des dispositifs
on peut par exemple aussi ça va être un
peu la branche et écologistes on peut on
peut travailler sur des pistes pour
augmenter le pouvoir d'achat comme par
exemple le réemploi des fauteuils des
fauteuils roulants créé tout un réseau
ça se fait dans d'autres départements il
ya des choses à mettre en place pour
permettre l'amélioration du pouvoir
d'achat et et garantir la meilleure
reste à vie pour ces personnes-là à la
shoah yad et vous voulez ajouter quelque
chose oui je veux la paix dont je veux
ajouter quelque chose parce que quand
monsieur krattinger n'est pas d'accord
sur un sujet et dit c'est pas moi c'est
l'état bon mais il fait les routes
nationales à la place de l'état avec
l'argent des contribuables haut saônois
j'ai entendu qu'il n'était pas d'accord
avec notre proposition
dont acte jeudi que la saône-et-loire en
trois ans a déjà recruté 70 médecins ils
ont quasiment réglé le problème
je suis allé voir le président il ya
quelques temps on a passé trois heures
ensemble
je m'explique bien comment tout ça a été
fait sur le plan réglementaire sur le
plan législatif il n'y a aucun problème
et puis la chose qui me choque c'est sûr
krattinger parce que c'est ce que vous
venez de dire on va régler le problème
des médecins en obligeant les médecins à
aller s'installer à tel ou tel endroit
c'est ce que vous dites mais c'est
vraiment sécurisé mais si voilà alors
vous a expliqué un jeune médecin
bravo vous expliqué un jeune médecin
vous serez médecin mais si vous voulez
que vos patients soient pris en charge
par la sécurité sociale vous allez vous
installer à tel endroit pourtant tourné
on ne peut pas on ne peut pas obliger un
médecin à s'engager dans un secteur qui
ne lui plaît pas donc l'attractivité du
système que je propose c'est dommage on
n'a pas suffisamment de temps mais je
pourrais vous expliquer pourquoi les 60
restants sont venus en saône-et-loire de
paris de marseille de toute la france
est riche il ya une évolution de la
médecine je voudrais juste par rapport à
la proposition donc de can't have cost
le rsa jeunes ouvre on l'appelle
autrement vous êtes pour vous êtes
contre d'écouter tout ce qui est tout ce
qui peut venir en aide
un autre jeunesse à la jeunesse qui n'a
pas d'autres moyens
je suis tout à fait d'accord pour qu'on
le fasse mais sur des critères qu'ils
soient les critères vraiment jusqu'à ce
que moi je suis pour la justice sociale
pour moi la meilleure insertion c'est le
travail c'est la valeur travail
c'est la formation et les jeunes qui
sont actuellement en déroute parce qu'il
y en a beaucoup et il ya eu la preuve du
coc vide trouver des stages ça c'est une
autre proposition qui est dans notre
programme
si je suis élu président du département
je m'engage dans la première année à
trouver mille stage mille stages aux
jeunes qui sont à la recherche d'un
stage qui va leur permettre d'avoir leur
formation en alternance
il galère pour l'instant je trouve que
c'est et ça coûte rien c'est de la
volonté politique
c'est la raison des remises je termine
justement des paroles que je préfère ça
un chèque sans contrepartie
lorsqu'on n'a pas beaucoup dagnan
antoine villedieu encore un mot sur le
social ce que vous nous avez parlé de la
chaude les mineurs non accompagnés vous
avez peut-être d'autres propositions
afin évidemment donc par rapport à la
jeunesse
je pense que ce qui me plaît pas
effectivement seul terme rsa jeunes
parce que le rsa c'est pour les plus de
25 ans d'accompagner la jeunesse
il faut que le département de vienne
comment dire le premier acteur le
premier acteur c'est déjà en travaillant
sur l'exclusion de la ruralité en
permettant aux jeunes de d'étudier de
d'anticiper leur avenir de faire des
projets de découvrir parle par la
culture par notre patrimoine local
partout ce qui peut aujourd'hui remettre
un lien social mais il ya aussi une
autre chose qu'on parle peut-être plus
sur le plan national puisque la
malheureuse actualité nous l'a rappelé
récemment sont les femmes victimes de
violences conjugales
les jeunes victimes d'homophobie
transphobie ces jeunes victimes
d'exclusion de harcèlement et bien
nouveau
une fois président du département on
mettra on permettra aux associations un
financement plus important pour
développer les maisons d'accueil pour
avoir cette petite bulle sanitaire de la
violence enfin dont vous avez la part je
voudrais vous poser deux trois petites
questions parce que tout à l'heure
yves krattinger ya répondu ici il reste
président il veut bien que les routes
passe de 80 à 90 km heure vous en dites
quoi vous mais la politique du
rassemblement final elle a été très
clair dès le départ c'est à dire que
continuer cette fallait pas baisser
n'allait pas baisser donc nous
effectivement au même si on aura la
majorité quand on aura la majorité prise
il a majoritairement art dont
département d'état vous ne paraissez
encore présidentielle on
remettra les routes éligibles je précise
bien à 90 km/heure très rapidement parce
que vous êtes en avance en temps de
parole ont pas monsieur krattinger
manque pas de souffle parce qu'il
commence pour son propos en dix ans qui
veut remettre le 90 a fait trois séances
de suite que le groupe de droite lui
propose il refuse
on a fait une conférence de presse
j'étais avec eux on a fait des fautes au
bord de la route avec un panneau 90 pour
dire il faut vraiment ils ont encore
voter non il nous détaille la cour à
titre personnel mais en même temps il ya
une majorité donc sa majorité ne le
suivrait pas franchement poste pour le
retour aux 90 km heure ou pas le 80 km
heure il permet malgré tout de sauver
des vies donc je pense qu'il faut faire
du cas par cas il ya peut-être des
routes qu'on peut remettre à 90 et
d'autres qu'il faut peut-être maintenir
à 80 km/heure vous opiné du chef vous
êtes d'accord sélectif à sélectif le moi
je voudrais juste vous poser aux uns et
aux autres deux ou trois petites
questions un petit peu plus politique
si au premier tour quant à votre
candidat se retrouve derrière un
candidat soutenu par la majorité d'yves
krattinger ce qu'au deuxième tour vous
appeler à voter pour lui ça c'est le
collectif qu'il déterminera en temps et
on ne voulait pas m'ennuyer
pour le moment on est sur le premier
tour et on va reporter c'est quand la
question inverse aussi yves krattinger
si l'un de vos candidats et derrière un
candidat de l'union de la gauche est ce
que vous appeler à voter pour lui au
deuxième tour je pense voter aussi en
cours on touche on verra maintenant
septembre botté en touche tous non non
c'est pas botter en touche et je
comprends la réponse qui a été donné on
ne sait pas les taux de participation on
sait qu'il faut deuxième lui % des
inscrits pour avoir un droit absolu au
deuxième tour on ne sait pas comment ça
va se passer donc prendre des décisions
aujourd'hui avec un horizon il ya du
brouillard partout des nuages
non je pense qu'il faut être raisonnable
j'ai toujours appelé à un vote eux qu'on
appelle enfin ses classiques de barrage
mais après j'attends de voir ce qui va
se passer dans les cantons en parlant de
barrages si jamais un candidat du
rassemblement national est en passe de
gagner un canton est ce que vous allez
appelé à faire barrage contre le fn
houba
si bien sûr votre candidat n'est plus en
course mais vous et que vous savez quoi
je suis chef de file qu'est ce que ça
veut dire chef de file ça veut dire que
derrière il ya une équipe comme tout le
monde vient de le dire et un collectif
qui verra ça le moment venu pour
l'instant des échanges on aussi délais
sont les électeurs se prononcent et sont
pas des enfants les électeurs vous
prenez infantiliser ce que vous savez la
question que vous posez ja ça suppose
que quelqu'un soit plus au deuxième tour
déjà les gens ont voté pour lui au
premier tour puisqu'il est plus là au
deuxième tour donc il rentre chez lui et
en plus il faudrait qu'ils leur disent
pour qu'ils vont voter au deuxième set
quand même tu peu audacieuse madame
c'est ce qui me caractérise l'audace
justement il krattinger qu'elle est
quelles sont vos relations avec la
république en marche le parti
présidentiel je ne suis pas membre
république en marche je n'ai jamais été
mais certains vous disent comme par
exemple parce que vous avez dériver vers
le centre voire à droite derrière le
centre est toujours de sécurité de 22
personnes de gauche alors c'est quand
même pas mal comme voilà donc comme je
suis avec une majorité de gauche modérée
certains plus à gauche d'autres un peu
moins à gauche mais tout le monde est à
gauche donc je ne renie rien du tout
d'ailleurs monsieur joyandet a bien
identifié puisqu'elle a écrit 24 ans de
socialisme
d'ailleurs on pourrait peut-être juste
en profiter aujourd'hui dans un élan de
sincérité sur l'agglomération de vesoul
ya deux cantons vesoul s vesoul où est
ce qu'ils ont investi tueur de la droite
et du centre ce sont nos candidats le
maire de vesoul nous vous parliez tout à
l'heure présente quatre candidats sur
vesoul est venu l'ouest vous n'avez pas
présenté de candidat contre eux est ce
que ça veut dire que ce sont aussi vos
candidats je n'ai pas exclu et de choses
dans ce sens et je ne le ferai pas parce
que s'ils génèrent voteront jeu alors
moi je l' ai juste éclairé donc nous
avons benoît thomas sens sylvie manière
est thomas ou d'eau qui était l air lors
des produits précédents scrutins en 2015
et qui sont proches d'alain chrétiens
qui lui a quitté les l air et qui est
maintenant agir la droite constructive
et ses trois élus ont rejoint en cours
de l'ue en cours de route
la majorité d'yves krattinger et qui
veut avec lui donnant on a je pense
qu'on a compris le rien de sortir un
journal départemental des landes
là les gens dont vous parlez c'est pas
dans le bouillonnant la juste réponse à
ça je dis je vais être un peu plus
factuel puisque sur notre liste
départementale vous n'êtes pas sans
savoir que vous avez l'attaché
parlementaire de christophe lejeune qui
est député la grande arche juste une
question et vous me répondu très
rapidement
julien odoul vos têtes de liste aux
élections régionales rassemblement
national est en plein dans une tourmente
de polémique
est ce que ça vous gêne pour les
départementales ou pas est-ce que ça me
gêne ce qui me gêne c'est la bassesse
des attaques d'un journal d'extrême
gauche libération
c'est des propos abjects mensonges et
des propos on est allé chercher une
vidéo quand même qu'il a fait durant sa
jeunesse qui faisait du mannequinat pour
têtu voilà allez on va parce je suis
désolé les adhérents puisqu'il reste un
peu plus de deux minutes et vous avez
messieurs chacun 30 secondes pour
conclure à la jambe ou un an d'essai
vous qui compte
attention je fais attention à 30
secondes pas une de plus
je prouve que chacun a vu que notre
projet existe qu'il est sérieux qu'il
est aux antipodes de ce que monsieur
krattinger a fait pendant 20 ans je
pense qu'il est urgent de mettre fin à
cette politique injuste très sélective
et de nous faire confiance parce que sur
tous les sujets nous allons faire des
choses pour l'ensemble des hauts saônois
et pas que pour une partie de territoire
que vous savez à titre personnel
pourquoi je m'engage dans cette affaire
compliquée pour moi puisque je me
présente contre des candidats sortants
je ne suis donc pas favori ce que j'ai
fait pour vesoul ce que j'ai fait pour
le vesoul et le crédit qu'on m'accorde
pour ce que j'ai fait pour vesoul
je souhaite le faire pour la haute saône
antoine villedieu pour le rassemblement
national cible alors voilà c'est bon je
vais très simple je dis vous me
connaissez j'ai pas besoin de me
déguiser faire semblant je me suis
engagé pour mon département par
conviction uniquement par conviction
vous savez que je suis pas non plus
candidat aux élections régionales c'est
un choix personnel
certains sont venus bilé par l'idée de
faire baja barrage au rassemblement
national et bien moi je suis déterminé à
l'idée de protéger de protéger les
personnes en situation de handicap
nos aînés nos jeunes notre patrimoine et
notre identité
merci beaucoup quant à frost donc pour
le parti communiste
[Musique]
moi j'aimerais rajouter quelque chose
notre liste ce qu'elle défend c'est le
renouveau démocratique
on le voit on a un président ça fait 20
ans qu'il est accroché à son poste on à
monsieur joyandet qui ne cesse de
s'accrocher également ainsi mandat
électif
nous c'est le renouveau démocratique et
comment ça se fait si on veut
aujourd'hui lutter contre l'abstention
il faut redonner la parole aux citoyens
et notamment une des propositions que
l'on fait c'est à la création de comités
départementaux très bien merci beaucoup
yves krattinger 30 secondes et pas une
de plus le département c'est l'humain
avant tout ce sont les enfants les
jeunes les familles les personnes
handicapées les personnes âgées nous
sommes au coeur du quotidien des gens en
proximité
éducation le sport la culture les
mobilités le département il doit aussi
préparer l'avenir
ce sont les grandes infrastructures la
fibre l'eau l'alimentation l'énergie etc
et les diminutions du co2 nous avons
beaucoup fait évoluer la haute-saône et
chacun le reconnaît vite
enfin si nice évoque elle puisse être
fière d'elle-même et j'ai toujours eu de
vrai dans ce sens je le ferai si je suis
réélu merci au club continue merci
beaucoup il s'agit de faire la course en
tête
merci beaucoup monsieur merci de votre
attention pour se retrouve dans quelques
instants pour le territoire de belfort a
tout de suite
[Musique]